hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
special edition of modeling the Masters
today we're going to look at my favorite
seven boldest entrepreneur moves of all
time these are from entrepreneurs who
risk everything to take their shot at
success and against all odds they made
it I hope you find their stories
inspirational and take some lessons from
their success here we go
bold move number seven Milton Hershey
doesn't give up Milton Hershey was a
founder of the Hershey Chocolate Company
who was one of the 20th century's most
successful entrepreneurs but also one of
the country's most generous
philanthropists today the Hershey
company continues to reign as the
world's largest chocolate company with
more than 13,000 employees and over five
billion dollars in sales at the age of
19 against his parents wishes her she
decided to go to Philadelphia in toward
the start of his own caramel company the
business was never able to generate a
profit and was forced to close six years
later her she refused to give up
traveled throughout Denver New York
Chicago and New Orleans trying to find
fortune each time but he was
unsuccessful he returned home at age 28
with no money and was seen as a
disgraced by his family but he still
refused to give up he started a new
business with a former employee of his
and moved from making caramels to
chocolate after ten years of failure
Hershey finally hit on a winning
business his company expanded year after
year and if he had listened to his
friends and family through those ten
years of failure we would never have
known the Hershey chocolate bar
bold move number six Ted Turner decides
to be successful Ted Turner is a founder
of CNN and Turner Broadcasting System
he owns the Atlanta Braves gave 1
billion dollars United Nations and
currently has a net worth of 1.9 billion
dollars Turner had a lot of bad luck
growing up he was a C student at school
got expelled from University had his
parents divorce got divorce by his wife
and had a sister developed terminal
lupus he went to work for his father's
outdoor advertising company when his
father then killed himself because he
couldn't pay off the company's debts Ted
Turner at the age of 24 took over the
company restore to the profitability and
began building his empire he had all the
odds stacked against him he was
determined to be a success
according to Turner all my life people
have said that I wasn't going to make it
I've never run into a guy who could win
at the top level in anything today and
didn't have the right attitude didn't
give it everything he had at least while
he was doing it wasn't prepared and
didn't have the whole program worked out
bold move number 5 George Lucas
challenges traditional business models
George Lucas is one of the film
industry's most financially successful
independent directors and producers with
an estimated net worth of 3 billion
dollars he is best known for his star
wars in Indiana Jones movies where Lucas
is first movies didn't give a financial
return on investment he found it
difficult to find support for his latest
idea
new movie called Star Wars to get the
movie into production he waved his
upfront fee as a director and agreed to
own the licensing rights so he could
profit from any toys t-shirts and other
products that came from the movie at the
time movie studios didn't see licensing
rights as valuable so they agreed the
money he made from the licensing rights
alone allowed him to finance his sequels
himself and built his fortune
according to Lucas my first six years in
business were hopeless there were a lot
of times when you sit and you say why am
I doing this I'll never make it it's
just not going to happen I should go out
and get a real job and try to survive I
thought Star Wars was too wacky for the
general public right or wrong this is my
movie this is my decision and this is my
creative vision and if people don't like
it they don't have to see it
bold move number four Anita Roddick is
forced to survive Anita Roddick was a
founder of the body shop a cosmetics
company known for its environmental and
ethical best practices in 2006 she sold
the company to L'Oreal for six hundred
and fifty two point three million pounds
she got married
Radek tan her husband Gordon set up a
small atrium hotel to support their
family then her husband decided he
wanted to fulfill his lifelong dream of
riding a horse
from Buenos Aires Argentina to New York
City in order to support her family
while her husband was gone
she started the body shop the bank
rejected her $8,000 loan request so she
got the money from a local gas station
owner to get the business up and running
while looking after her two children on
her own accord an erotic for myself I
needed to earn money look after the kids
while my husband was traveling for two
years across South America I started the
body shop in 1976 simply to create a
livelihood for myself on my $2.00 while
my husband Gordon was trekking across
the Americas
I had no training our experience and my
only business acumen was boarded vice to
take sales 300 pounds a week nobody
talks of entrepreneurship a survival but
that's exactly what it is and what
nurtures creative thinking bold loop
number three a pigeon they need bets on
the little guy Amedeo Peter Giannini
revolutionized the banking world by
providing services to the little guy
Giannini passed away 1949 at the age of
79 for that time his bank that had
founded the Bank of America had become
the largest bank in the world with more
than five hundred and twenty five
branches in over 300 cities before AP
Giannini you can only get a loan if you
already had some money hard-working
immigrants like his parents didn't
qualify and Giannini wanted to change
the system he set up his bank across the
street from a popular bank and began
making loans to people other banks
wouldn't give a chance when a massive
earthquake hit San Francisco in 1906 all
the banks in the city closed down to
assess their damage people couldn't get
access to their funds at the time they
needed it the most
the earthquake demolished Ginny's Bank
but he opened up shop by setting up a
desk using two barrels a plank of wood
across them he would lend money to
people based on a handshake to help them
rebuild their lives he also went on to
find entrepreneurs like Walt Disney
nobody believed in and projects like the
Golden Gate Bridge that were considered
too crazy to invest in
bold move number two guy laliberté risks
it all in Los Angeles
fellow Canadian Guy Laliberte is a
founder of Cirque du Soleil a circus
entertainment company who shows have
been seen by almost 100 million people
worldwide in 2006 libertate was named
the Ernst and Young Entrepreneur of the
year and his current net worth is over
2.5 billion dollars after couple years
of marginal success but the de verte
decided to risk everything to perform at
the Los Angeles Arts Festival booked as
the opening act the performances was
going to be watched by many big names
including high-profile Hollywood
celebrities according to la liberté who
was live or die in LA and we bet
everything on one night by the end of
the show we had standing ovations the
day after tickets were selling like
crazy I bet everything on that one night
if we failed
there was no cash for gas to come home
bold move number one Walt Disney does
the impossible Walt Disney was a film
producer animator and entertainer he
created films with iconic characters
like Mickey Mouse 122 Academy Awards and
established a Disney theme parks today
the Walt Disney Company has revenues of
over 35 billion dollars per year at a
young age Walt Disney had some modest
success with animated short films when
he decided to do the boldest move ever
in his industry make a full-length
animated feature film it had never been
done before let alone in color and with
music his competitors associates and
even his wife thought he would never
make it originally budgeted at $500,000
the project had gone over budget by half
a million dollars in his early stages
Disney was forced to act out the film's
story in front of bankers in order to
secure the additional loans he needed to
finish it in the end Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs went on to earn four times
the box office of any other film when it
was released according to Disney somehow
I can't believe there are any Heights
that can't be scaled by a man who knows
the secret of making dreams come true
this special secret seems to me can be
summarized in the four seas they are
curiosity confidence courage and
constancy and the greatest of these is
confidence
thank you for joining me for this
special edition of modeling the masters
I hope you enjoyed please give it a
thumbs up below if you want to see more
videos and leave a comment and love to
hear your feedback stay tuned for the
next episode
you